astros with a magic number of two a win
today in oakland combined with a loss by
the mariners in anaheim with the game
starting at the same time the astros can
claim a fourth division title in five
years well mr blackburn fellow that's
itching to get it cranking kite making
his eighth start of the season for the
oakland a's
and that's down and in ball four so a
good battle there alex bregman wins it
by drawing a walk
good clutch hitter
chapman's got it spins around throws in
time and that'll do it jake odorizzi is
going to be the man on the mound 22
games this season 21 of them have been
starts this will be the first start
since he left that game in texas after
going an inning and a third with that
right foot soreness
oh there you go a little fastball up and
in martay checking to see if that was a
strike either way he goes down swinging
up and away so olson long at bat
on the ground
let miss diaz will flip it to jose
altuve and that'll do it for the a's in
the first inning
[Music]
that one's driven toward the gap left
center field and that'll get down it's
cut off on the warning track by
mccormick who gets it back in but it's
going to be a lead off double for brown
[Applause]
foul tip caught by castro that'll be a
strikeout of chapman
[Music]
center field
siri back
now he's got enough room and he makes
the catch and he
shows off his arm and it's a pretty good
one
two out seth brown over third there is
tony left-handed hitter it's hit hard
and it's a base hit right center field
brown comes in to score tony kemp with a
two-out rbi single to give the a's a
one-nothing lead
[Music]
and that's right there strike three call
perfect pitch on the outside corner and
that's the first strikeout for paul
blackburn
here's al toube swings and slams with up
the middle to his left tony gloves spins
gets up throws and gets out duvet
another tony kemp kind of play
as he retires el tube one two three
[Music]
it's diaz the throw is high and it's
pass to first baseman guriel harrison
who went head first into first base pops
up and ends up at second base with
nobody out we're not even going to mess
around with it here just
dusty says
go on big fella in the pitch
driven to left field it's got carry on
it and it's going to be caught by
mccormick
[Applause]
matt chapman has it matt chapman
throws out one
away grounds it right to shore
harrison flips it across and paul
blackburn is rolling
this is going to work so with the shift
on tony kemp just really hit he just
kind of rolled it towards short but
nobody was there
[Applause]
black drive right field that's gonna get
down for a hit
a little two out rally for the athletics
thanks to kemp and jan jones
the ball to left field hit pretty well
mccormick back near the wall and he will
put it away in front of the wall for the
final out of the inning harrison made a
bid but came up short and odor rizzy
will walk off after four innings with
the a's leading one to nothing
now here's the 3-2 pitch swing on the
ground ball left side deep short
backhand harrison long throw across the
diamond in time
excellent play by josh harrison
well this is the sinker that they had
been trying to get diaz to top they
finally got him to offer it one kept it
fair jay hey with a great effort across
his body enough on it
[Music]
there's a ball off the glove of olson
tony kemp or josh harrison can't make
the play
and that should be the first hit of the
game for the astros
there's a ball up the middle
back-to-back base hits for the astros
castro a big turn he's going to head to
third and the astros with two outs with
their first two hits of the game chaz
mccormick follows up castro's hit see if
jose siri can continue this sitting as
the astros with their first rally of the
game first runner in scoring position
[Applause]
towards the middle diving stop by
harrison but everybody's going to be
safe and the astros get a run jason
castro scores a run and we're all tied
up christian javier taking over in the
fit
that's a good way to start things off
marte felt like that was off the plate
but javier picks up a strikeout at 95.
big swing no contact and javier with
back-to-back strikeouts getting marta
looking at olson swinging for out number
two 51st appearance for garrett he's 4-1
with a 3.36 era
bregman leads off against guerra he's
walked and grounded out two and two on
the way
alex bregman drills one to left field
down the line and that ball is gone home
run alex bregman
the astros have their first lead of the
day on bregman's 11th home run of the
season
oh bregman gives the astros the lead
here in the sixth inning on what could
be a clinch day in oakland
little q shot the other way tough play
for chapman you're not safe
alvarez beats the throw chapman did
everything he could so one on and nobody
out for guriel who is o for two with a
couple of groundouts
guiley sends one into center field hit
deep this ball is going to be down and
off the wall you're not on the move he
can trot home the astros now take a
three to one lead julie guriel an rbi
double and it's three to one
swinging a miss javier has struck out
all four he has faced today as he gets
seth brown on strikes one away in the
sixth
[Music]
and that's gonna be a base hit tony kemp
is three for three
[Applause]
and like a breaking ball that hit john
goes
[Music]
butted
machine with a nice job and he's going
to move up both the runners to second
and third with one out and now the tying
run and scoring position the a's are
sending starly marty to the plate
hit hard right to altuve it's gonna get
a run home
kemp trots in to score to make it three
to two so two outs now with sky bolt at
third so marte picks up his 54th rbi 3-2
game runner on third in the seventh big
spot for phil maton
not close nowhere close
see if canada can deliver here he's old
for three a's down three two in the
seventh they picked up one run
there's the slider that's a fair ball
breakfast knocks it down everybody's
safe runs scores and we're tied
[Applause]
but he walks jordan on here
yeah that's not even in the vicinity now
euless shoots one to right field
jordan will stay at second he thought
about going first to third against seth
brown
sweet missy struck him out straight
fastball 92 miles an hour
to right field
brown is there and he's got it so
chaffin gets out of the jam
mccormick strikes out for the second
time one away top of the night
that's why ball hits a shallow left
field racing in canna that's going to
drop in front of him jose siri reaches
with a bloop hit his second hit today
pitch is right on the inside corner
perfect pitch he struck him out looking
well the only advantage now with a count
three and two is siri will be off with
the pitch so any ball towards the gap
should give the astros a lead
here he runs again and the ball is
looped into right center for a hit
surrey is digging for third he'll take a
look back he's going to try to score the
throw to the plate is there he is out so
siri trying to score from first on a
single and he is fast but tony kemp got
it he threw home
called out
murphy base hit center field right off
the end of the bat
[Applause]
it's bunted in a diving attempt by
guriel it pops off his glove and
everybody's safe
to the backstop runners will move up
second and third nobody out tough spot
for ryan presley bases loaded one out
bottom half of the ninth inning of a tie
game so here is mark canna against ryan
presley bases loaded one out
in a tie ball game first pitch is driven
left center field nobody's gonna get it
and the a's are gonna walk it off for
the second day in a row to finish off a
three-game sweep of the houston astros
[Applause]